YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US NOW
FROM THE BORDER.
LET’S BRING IN LOUISIANA SENATOR
JOHN KENNEDY.
HE’S JOINING US FROM LOUISIANA
ON THIS MONDAY.
SENATOR GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: WELL YOU LOOK AT WHAT’S
GOING ON ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
BACK IN MARCH, JOE BIDEN WHEN HE
WAS TRYING TO EXPLAIN WHY SO
MANY PEOPLE WERE SURGING IN
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY AND MARCH,
HE SAID YOU KNOW, THAT’S JUST
WHAT HAPPENS DURING WINTER
MONTHS WHEN IT’S COOLER.
WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE COMING
THROUGH, AND NOW WE’RE IN THE
SUMMER MONTHS AND WE’VE GOT
MUCH BIGGER NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
COMING THROUGH, SO OBVIOUSLY,
THE PRESIDENT’S LOGIC ON COOLER
WEATHER, HOTTER WEATHER, NOT
COMPLETELY ACCURATE.
>> WELL I THINK THAT’S TRUE,
AND I DON’T THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS EVER TOLD THE
TRUTH ABOUT THE BORDER.
I READ THE ARTICLE ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN, BIDEN’S
DECISION TO PAY THE CONTRACTORS
$2 BILLION NOT TO BUILD A WALL,
NOT TO FINISH THE WALL, AND HERE
IS MY CONCLUSION ABOUT THAT.
WHAT DO YOU CALL A GENIUS IN
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S HOMELAND
SECURITY DEPARTMENT?
A VISITOR.
BRIAN:  [LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT HE’S DOING IS A CRIME
AGAINST NATURE AND INTELLIGENCE,
FOR TWO REASONS.
NUMBER ONE, IT’S AN OBSCENE
WASTE OF TAXPAYER MONEY.
SENATE REPUBLICANS ARE SCRAMBL
ING RIGHT NOW TO PASS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT’S
PAID FOR.
WE COULD USE THIS $2 BILLION
THAT HE IS WASTING, THAT WOULD
OVERLAY ABOUT 1,600 MILES OF
FOUR-LANE HIGHWAYS.
NUMBER TWO, BORDER WALLS IN
TERMS OF BORDER SECURITY ARE A
FAT GUY LAYUP.
THERE’S A REASON THAT SAUDI
ARABIA HAS A 500-MILE BORDER
WALL WITH IRAQ.
THERE’S A REASON THAT ISRAEL HAS
A 400-MILE BORDER WALL IN ITS
COUNTRY.
THERE’S A REASON THAT THERE’S A
BORDER WALL BETWEEN NORTH AND
SOUTH KOREA.
THERE’S A REASON THAT FRANCE HAS
A BORDER WALL AND BULGARIA.
BORDER WALLS WORK AND WE’VE HAD
A BORDER WALL FOR 30 YEARS IN
AMERICA.
EVERY PRESIDENT SINCE THEN HAS
SUPPORTED IT INCLUDING PRESIDENT
OBAMA AND PRESIDENT CLINTON,
EXCEPT PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I THINK THE CONCLUSION IS ALMOST
INESCAPABLE, FOLKS, THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN BELIEVES IN OPEN
BORDERS.
BRIAN:  YEAH, HE VOTED FOR IT
WHEN IN 2006, THERE’S NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT WOULD HELP SO NOW WE
PAID THIS MONEY, NOW WE’RE GOING
TO PAY $2 BILLION TO STORE OR
DESTROY A WALL THAT WE NEED.
ITS ALL BEEN BECAUSE HE DOESN’T
LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I THINK
IT’S THE ANTI-LEADERSHIP
EVERYTHING YOU DON’T WANT IN A
PRESIDENT.
>> WELL I THINK IT’S ALSO AN
INDICATION THAT LET’S BE
HONEST, PRESIDENT BIDEN DIDN’T
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
TRUTH WHEN HE WAS RUNNING.
HE BELIEVES IN OPEN BORDERS AND
HE BELIEVES THE BORDER IS A
NUISANCE THAT VETTING PEOPLE AT
THE BORDER IS RACIST, HE THINKS
ANYBODY OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO COME
INTO AMERICA.
SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN
IN OFFICE, 1 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
COME INTO AMERICA FROM THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND DON’T
HAVE THE SLIGHTEST IDEA WHO THEY
ARE.
STEVE: WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE
SENATOR KENNEDY THANK YOU VERY